nous sommes ici au centre ville de kiev
et depuis quelques semaines l'armée
ukrainienne a installés sur cette place
centre-ville une place très populaire
une attraction assez singulière il
s'agit en fait des pav d'armements
russes donc on peut y trouver des
camions des chars d'assaut des canes ont
toutes été détruits par l'artillerie
ukrainienne alors c'est devenu un lieu
de pèlerinage pour les petits et grands
et ce qui est très particulier si vous
ne le sentirais évidemment pas à travers
la vidéo mais il règne ici une forte
odeur chimique probablement toxique rien
n'a été décontaminés au préalable et ça
n'empêche pas du tout en fait même des
enfants de rentrer dans ses équipements
de jouer même avec les canons alors
c'est une attraction assez curieuse mais
qui est très populaire ici dans une
ville où finalement on est relativement
épargné par les bombardements des
dernières semaines des bombardements
évidemment que l'on sent beaucoup plus
présents dans l'est du pays dans le
débat ce qui est vraiment à des
centaines de kilomètres de la capitale
ukrainienne